Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishist tea were emptied into the sea. This morning, a man of war sails. This is the most magnificent movement of all. There is a dignity, a majesty, a sublimity in this last effort of the patriots that I greatly admire. The people should never rise without doing something to be remembered,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社团，请访问 therestishist...茶叶被倾倒进大海。今天，一艘军舰扬帆起航。这是所有行动中最宏伟的一幕。爱国者们的这最后一搏，有着一种尊严、一种宏大、一种崇高，令我无比钦佩。人民不应该在没有留下值得铭记的事迹之前就盲目起义，
something notable and striking. This destruction of the tea is so bold, so daring, so firm, intrepid and inflexible, and it must have so important consequences and so lasting that I can't but consider it as an epoch in history. So that, Dominic, was John Adams. And we agreed in the previous episode that we've been doing on the American War of Independence, that that's exactly how Americans spoke. They spoke like people from Devon. And he was writing on the 16th of december 1773 yes about a tea related anglo-american imbroglio so you may remember that a few months ago there
做一些值得注意和轰动的事。这场倾倒茶叶的行动是如此大胆、如此果敢、如此坚定、无畏且坚决，它必然会带来如此重要且持久的后果，以至于我不得不认为它是历史上的一个纪元。多米尼克，刚才那就是约翰·亚当斯。我们在之前关于美国独立战争的节目中一致认为，这正是美国人说话的方式。他们说话的语气就像德文郡来的人。他写信的时间是1773年12月16日，没错，谈论的是一场与茶相关的英美纠纷。所以大家可能还记得，几个月前
was great outrage in britain because um an american youtuber suggested making tea by boiling the water in a microwave yeah which was shocking which was shocking and shows that really i mean americans are still up to their tea related tea related atrocity but this is so this is the kind of the primal anglo-american tea related bust up isn't it the tea party although it didn't actually get that name for 50 years um until after the actual event absolutely right tom um hello everybody welcome back uh and just to be absolutely clear we've done quite a lot of linguistic research until after the actual event. Absolutely right, Tom. Hello, everybody. Welcome back. And just to be absolutely clear, we've done quite a lot of linguistic research,
英国曾引发巨大愤怒，因为呃，一个美国网红建议用微波炉烧水来泡茶，哈哈，这太令人震惊了，这太令人震惊了，这确实表明——我的意思是，美国人仍然在搞这种跟茶有关的、跟茶有关的暴行。但这就是——这就是那种最初的英美因茶而起的争端，对吧？也就是波士顿倾茶事件，尽管直到50年后的实际事件发生很久之后，它才真正被称为这个名字。完全正确，汤姆，大家好，欢迎回来。为了绝对清楚起见，我们做了相当多的语言学研究，直到实际事件发生很久之后。完全正确，汤姆。大家好，欢迎回来。为了绝对清楚起见，我们做了相当多的语言学研究，
haven't we, Tom? Yes. That absolutely is how the founding fathers sounded. And we have an absolute top historian, Oxford professor Adam Smith, an expert on American history. And Adam, that's right, isn't it? Tom's accent was pretty much syllable perfect.
对吧，汤姆？是的。这绝对就是国父们的发音。我们请来了一位顶级历史学家、牛津大学教授亚当·史密斯，他是美国历史专家。亚当，对吧？汤姆的口音简直可以说是字正腔圆。
Is that correct? Spot on. I think, Tom, if anything, we're just speaking a bit too morosely because I think John Adams had a kind of greater sense of drive, but I think the accent was spot on. Okay, well, next time I'll bear that in mind. So the Boston Tea Party, this exists in the context of everything that we were discussing in the previous episode, the kind of the growing disagreements between the British government to regulate imperial trade by boycotting British goods. And the British government have decided that they will kind of
是这样吗？完全正确。汤姆，如果非要说有什么不足的话，我觉得我们的语气稍微有点太郁闷了，因为我觉得约翰·亚当斯有一种更强的进取心，但我觉得这个口音绝对没问题。好吧，那我下次会记住的。那么波士顿倾茶事件，它的背景就是我们在上一集节目中讨论的一切，也就是英国政府通过抵制英国商品来规范帝国贸易的种种日益加剧的分歧。而英国政府决定，他们将——
reform all the various customs that they'd imposed on various products, including sugar, most notoriously. But by a majority of one, they vote to keep the duties on tea with calamitous consequences. Have I given a reasonably accurate summary there? So we need to talk about the Tea Act of 1773. So it wasn't just a matter of retaining the town's end duties on tea, although it did do that. The other town's end duties were repealed, but the one on tea was retained. But the Tea Act of 1773 was not really about America at all. I mean, it's critical to the story of the coming of the American Revolution, and the Americans thought it was all about them. It really wasn't about them at all. What it was actually about was the East India Company,
改革他们对各种产品（最著名的就是糖）征收的各种关税。但在多出一票的微弱多数下，他们投票决定保留对茶税的征收，并带来了灾难性的后果。我刚才的总结算得上相当准确吗？所以我们需要谈谈1773年的《茶叶法》。所以这不仅仅是保留唐森德茶税的问题，尽管它确实这样做了。其他唐森德关税都被废除了，唯独茶税被保留了下来。但1773年的《茶叶法》其实根本不是针对美国的。我的意思是，它是美国革命爆发故事中的关键环节，美国人以为这一切都是冲着他们来的。其实根本不是针对他们的。它真正针对的是东印度公司，
which was in serious financial trouble, falling revenues, huge stockpiles of tea in London warehouses, been a famine in Bengal that had affected its income, falling stock prices, credit crisis. And there were a lot of East India Company people in the House of Commons. This was deeply entwined with the British state. Basically, the East India Company was too big to fail. They needed a bailout. The bailout, which seemed like a very clever wheeze to the British government, seemed perfectly sensible, was that the East India Company would be allowed to directly export their India tea to the American colonies and the rest of the British Empire, rather than, as had previously been the case, having to sell to middlemen. The Americans saw this as a monopoly. It wasn't formally speaking
当时该公司陷入了严重的财务危机：营收下降、伦敦仓库里积压了巨额茶叶、孟加拉国发生了一场饥荒影响了其收入、股价下跌、信用危机。下议院里有大量东印度公司的人。这与英国国家体制深度交织。基本上，东印度公司大到不能倒。他们需要一笔纾困资金。这笔纾困资金对英国政府来说似乎是一个非常聪明的计策，显得完全合情合理，那就是允许东印度公司将他们的印度茶叶直接出口到美洲殖民地和英国的其他殖民帝国，而不是像以前那样必须卖给中间商。美国人将此视为一种垄断。从形式上讲，这并不是
a monopoly, but in practice, it would have enabled East India Company tea to be sold in the colonies at a price that would have undercut smuggled Dutch tea. So the British government thought this is a solution to all our problems. We allow the East India Company to offload our surplus tea, we provide cheaper tea to the colonies, and we do it legally, cutting off smuggling and thus reinforcing the Navigation Acts. Problem solved, except it wasn't. Yeah, why except it wasn't?
一种垄断，但在实践中，它将使东印度公司能够以低于走私荷兰茶的价格在殖民地销售茶叶。因此，英国政府认为这是解决我们所有问题的方法。我们允许东印度公司卸下我们过剩的茶叶，我们为殖民地提供更便宜的茶叶，而且我们是合法地这样做，切断了走私，从而巩固了《航海条例》。问题解决了，然而事实并非如此。是的，为什么说“然而事实并非如此”呢？
So the only people who lose out are smugglers, but presumably a lot of colonial Americans are involved in smuggling, are they? They are, but it's also the reassertion of the principle of parliamentary sovereignty, the right of Parliament, as Parliament saw it, to regulate American affairs, including fundamental issues like import and export. And that had been the issue that the colonists had been resisting for the previous 10 years or so. So it was another reassertion of parliamentary supremacy, which the colonists resisted. So on that issue, if we have any American listeners left, which I doubt, they will say in the last episode, you were very hard on the Americans. You know, you were very hard on the Americans. You saw it very much from London's perspective. And what we didn't mention, of course, was their great slogan, no taxation without representation. So if we were taking the American side seriously,
所以唯一利益受损的人是走私犯，但据推测，许多美洲殖民地居民都参与了走私，是吗？确实如此，但这同时也是对议会主权原则的重新宣示——按照议会的理解，议会有权规范美洲事务，包括进出口等根本性问题。而这正是殖民地居民在过去十年左右一直奋力抵抗的问题。因此，这是对议会至高无上地位的又一次重新宣示，遭到了殖民地居民的抵抗。所以关于这个问题，如果我们还有任何美国听众留下的话（我对此表示怀疑），他们会在上一集里说，你们对美国人太严厉了。你知道的，你们对美国人太严厉了。你们很大程度上是从伦敦的角度来看待这件事的。而当然，我们没有提到的是他们伟大的口号：无代表不纳税。所以如果我们认真采纳美洲人的立场，
they would say, we're not even represented in parliament. You can say that parliament is sovereign until you're blue in the face, but we don't have a single person in parliament you can say that parliament is sovereign till you're blue in the face but we don't have a single person in parliament to speak for us and you can claim we're virtually represented but we all know that's a sham no one cares about our interests yeah do they have a case there adam is that fair they do have a case they have a very they have a very very strong case and even the argument about virtual representation of course most people in britain couldn't vote either but at least you, I mean, you could try to make the case if you wanted to, that members of parliament at least knew their constituents, at least were aware of the issues in their home area. Whereas that definitely wasn't true for the American colonies, as we said in the
他们会说，我们在议会里甚至没有代表。你可以理直气壮地说议会拥有至高无上的主权，但我们在议会里连一个为我们说话的人都没有。你可以说议会拥有至高无上的主权直到你面红耳赤，但我们在议会里连一个为我们说话的人都没有，你还可以宣称我们是在虚拟代表制下被代表的，但我们都知道那是一场骗局，根本没有人关心我们的利益。是的，他们有道理吗，亚当？这公平吗？他们确实有道理。他们拥有非常、非常充分的理由，甚至关于虚拟代表制的论点——当然，英国大多数人也无法投票，但至少，我的意思是，如果你愿意的话，你可以试着去论证：议会议员至少认识他们的选民，至少了解他们本土地区的各种问题。然而对于美洲殖民地来说，情况绝对不是这样的，正如我们在
previous episode, hardly anybody sitting in the House of Commons had ever been to the colonies. And they were just a far off remote place where all kinds of assumptions were made, many of which were completely wrong. So yes, the colonies definitely did have a very good case. And that slogan, no taxation without representation, was not something they just invented from nothing in the 1760s. It was deeply rooted in their understanding of English liberties. And in Britain, presumably there are people who recognise this and who situate the debate in the kind of the broad traditions of English history as they had flowed over the previous two centuries, all the things that had resulted in the Civil War and the Glorious Revolution and
上一集所说，下议院里几乎没有人去过殖民地。对他们来说，那里只是一个遥远的地方，各种假设充斥其中，而其中许多假设完全是错误的。所以，是的，殖民地确实有着非常充分的理由。而“无代表不纳税”这个口号，并不是他们在18世纪60年代凭空捏造出来的。它深深植根于他们对英国自由的理解中。而在英国，想必也有人认识到这一点，并将这场辩论置于英国历史的广阔传统中，就像过去两个世纪以来所演变的那样，所有这些最终导致了内战、光荣革命等事件。人们觉得这是一场正在进行的意识形态辩论，其根源深深扎根于特殊的英国历史之中。
so on. A feeling that this is an ongoing ideological debate with deep roots in specifically British history. Absolutely. And there were some of them in Parliament. And we talked in the last episode about Isaac Paré and Edmund Burke. There were many outside of Parliament, including John Wilkes, who was a famous radical agitator, Thomas Paine, who later became famous after he moved in 1774 to Philadelphia. But those people represented this kind of country oppositional faction in British politics,
绝对是的。议会里确实有一些这样的人。我们在上一集里谈到了艾萨克·巴雷和埃德蒙·伯克。议会之外也有很多人，包括约翰·威尔克斯——他是一位著名的激进鼓动者，还有托马斯·潘恩——他在1774年移居费城后变得名声大噪。但这些人代表了英国政治中这种地方反对派阵营，
for whom the sort of more democratical culture of the American colonies was deeply appealing. They saw the American colonies as a more purified version of the English Republican tradition, which had been nurtured in the 1640s, and which they worried had become corrupted. And they weren't wrong to think that. I mean, obviously, 1770s England was a deeply aristocratic place. And you read the letters of Lord North and these government ministers and the king, and they're obsessing all the time. People are constantly petitioning them for titles. There's all this constant kind of factional politics within this aristocratic world.
美洲殖民地那种更具民主色彩的文化对他们有着巨大的吸引力。他们将美洲殖民地视为17世纪40年代孕育的英国共和主义传统的更纯粹版本，而他们担心这一传统已经遭到腐蚀。他们的这种想法并没有错。我的意思是，很显然，1770年代的英国是一个深深的贵族制社会。你读读诺斯勋爵、这些政府大臣以及国王的信件，他们满脑子都在痴迷这些事。人们不断向他们乞求头衔。在这个贵族世界内部，总是存在着这种持续不断的派系政治。
It was very alien. Although, Adam, just to reiterate, at this point, so just say on the eve of the Boston Tea Party, is there a mass Republican movement in America drawing on those kind of Cromwellian traditions? Or are the vast majority of Americans still loyal to the British crown? Well, so I suppose I'm using the 19th century a republic with a crown, just as arguably the United States becomes a republic with a monarch in the form of a president with huge prerogative power. So it's not necessarily the case, or it certainly isn't the case, that people in the colonies, very, very few people in the colonies up until 1774, 1775 are arguing for the creation of an independent republic.
这非常陌生。不过，亚当，重申一下，在这个时间点——也就是波士顿倾茶事件前夕，美国是否存在一个借鉴了那些克伦威尔式传统的大规模共和主义运动？还是说绝大多数美国人仍然忠于英国王室？好吧，所以我猜我是在借用19世纪的视角——一个带有王冠的共和国，就像可以说美国最终变成了一个由拥有巨大特权力的总统形式的君主所统治的共和国一样。因此，这并不一定意味着——或者说绝对不是指——殖民地的人民（在1774年、1775年之前，极少数极少数的人）在争取建立一个独立的共和国。
It's perfectly possible within that political tradition to have loyalty to the king, but still think of yourself as functionally republican. Because, of course, the crown of Great Britain was the freest in the world that the world had ever seen up until that time. And so they, at this stage, are still blaming the king's evil advisors. They are. They're blaming parliament and the king for being badly advised. Right. So to return to the issue of tea, the first tea ship to reach Boston is the Dartmouth, and I think that reaches Boston on the 28th of November 1773. And I mean, it sounds like such an abstruse issue, doesn't it? The taxation of tea. But there's a thousand people in Faneuil Hall in Boston
在那个政治传统内部，完全可以做到既忠于国王，同时又在功能上把自己视为共和主义者。因为，当然，大不列颠的王冠是那个时代乃至当时世界上所见过的最自由的王冠。因此，在这个阶段，他们仍然在指责国王身边的邪恶谋臣。是的，他们确实在指责。他们在指责议会和国王受到了坏人的误导。好，回到茶的问题上。抵达波士顿的第一艘茶船是“达特茅斯号”，我记得它是在1773年11月28日抵达波士顿的。我的意思是，这听起来是一个非常深奥的问题，对吧？对茶叶征税。但在波士顿的法尼尔厅里有一千人，
kind of shouting and waving bits of paper or whatever they do doing the opposite of huzzahs and saying what a terrible business this is. And basically they do not want the tea to be unloaded. That's the core thing, isn't it? They don't want the tea, which unloaded that's the core thing isn't it they don't want the tea which is in chests wooden chests i assume adam um and they just they won't let it onto the docks but under the law you can you can only stay in the port for 20 days before you have to go or your tea is taxed or there's some sort of weird regulations. And it all comes to a head on the 16th of December, 1773. And why do they...
他们在大喊大叫，挥舞着纸片什么的，或者做着与欢呼相反的举动，说着这是多么糟糕的一桩生意。基本上，他们不希望茶叶被卸载。这才是核心所在，对吧？他们不希望那些茶叶——卸载下来，这才是核心，对吧？他们不希望那些装在箱子里的茶叶，我猜是木箱子，亚当，呃，他们根本不让茶叶上码头。但根据法律，茶叶在港口最多只能停留20天，否则你就必须离开，否则你的茶叶就要被征税，或者有一些奇怪的法规。这一切在1773年12月16日达到了白热化。为什么他们……
So the famous... I saw a Lady Bird book illustration when I was about six, which involved people dressed up as Indians, as Native Americans. Is that true? I believe it is true, yes. They blacked their faces and dressed as mohawks, as disguises, and boarded the ship. And it was all very orderly. It was one of these kinds of organized mob actions where they took care not to
所以那个著名的……我大约六岁时看过一本“雷迪伯德”图书的插图，里面有人装扮成印第安人，也就是美洲原住民。这是真的吗？我相信这是真的，是的。他们把脸涂黑，打扮成莫霍克人作为伪装，然后登上了船。这一切都非常有秩序。这是一次那种有组织的暴民行动，他们在行动中小心翼翼地
break the locks if they could avoid doing so. They tried to get the keys to the ship's chests and so on. And their sole purpose was to destroy the tea, which they did. And it was known as the destruction of the tea. About £10,000 worth of tea was destroyed in Boston Harbour that night. They just chuck it overboard. Very poor respect for the ecology of the, very bad for the fish. Yes, but at this point, the lines that we will come to recognise in due course are still a bit scrambled. Benjamin Franklin, one of the great founding fathers, he describes this as an act of violent injustice.
避免破坏锁（如果能避免的话）。他们试图拿到船上箱子的钥匙等等。他们唯一的目的就是销毁茶叶，他们也确实这么做了。这就是著名的“倾茶事件”。那天晚上，价值大约一万英镑的茶叶在波士顿港被毁。他们直接把它扔进海里。对生态的尊重极其匮乏，对鱼类非常糟糕。是的，但此时，我们日后将会熟悉的那些界限仍然有些模糊。本杰明·富兰克林，伟大的国父之一，他将此描述为一种暴力非正义的行为。
Well, it's a destruction of property. So it really is crossing a line, even for many of those who'd been involved in resistance to Britain, many of whom were very conservative figures by most definitions of that word, and for whom the rights of property was fundamental. That, after all, was the point about no taxation without representation. You can't take my property away unless I have participated in the decision to allow you to do so. So does that take us to something about the revolutionaries? So you're John Adamses or Samuel Adams,
好吧，这是对财产的破坏。所以它确实越界了，甚至对许多曾参与抵制英国的人来说也是如此——他们中的许多人按照这个词的大多数定义来看都是非常保守的人物，对他们而言，财产权是根本。这毕竟就是“无代表不纳税”的意义所在。除非我参与了允许你这么做的决定，否则你不能拿走我的财产。那么这是否带我们走向了关于革命者的某些事情？所以你是约翰·亚当斯或塞缪尔·亚当斯，
and so he's a great sort of agitator in Boston, isn't he? A great agitator for liberty, as Americans would call him, and all these people who are members of groups like the Sons of Liberty or who, I don't know, what do they call them, correspondence committees, and they're all writing letters to people in Rhode Island or whatever they're doing. I mean, if that's how you get your kicks, crack on, as far as I'm concerned, but they're doing all that. Now, are they the propertied conservative classes? In other words, are they the establishment, as it were, or are they subversives, these people? Well, they are. Most of these people are
他是波士顿的一个伟大鼓动者，对吧？正如美国人所称的那样，他是一个伟大的自由鼓动者，所有这些加入“自由之子”等组织的人，或者，我不知道，他们管他们叫什么，通讯委员会，他们都在给罗德岛的人写信或者做诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，如果这就是你的乐趣所在，那就请便吧，就我而言，但他们确实在做所有这些。现在，他们是拥有财产的保守阶层吗？换句话说，他们是当权派，还是说这些人是颠覆分子？好吧，他们确实是。这些人大多数
definitely the propertied classes, yes. They're merchants and they're landowners and they're people who've been used to running their own affairs. And that's the fundamental problem. And in the South, there's a similar group of people in Virginia, and they're all own plantations and enslaved people. And these are the literate, sometimes highly educated, very articulate members of colonial society. And is it the case that as they find their material interests threatened, are they kind of scouting around for ideological justifications for that, that is something more than just it's our commercial interests that are being damaged? Or is that too cynical a view of it? I think it is too cynical a view of it, yes. I think they certainly did want to defend their material interests, but I think I wouldn't want to imply
绝对属于有产阶级，是的。他们是商人、土地所有者，是习惯于自己管理自己事务的人。这才是根本问题所在。而在南方，弗吉尼亚也有一个类似的群体，他们都拥有种植园和被奴役的人。这些人是殖民地社会中有文化、有时受过高等教育、口才极佳的成员。随着他们的物质利益受到威胁，他们是否在四处寻找意识形态上的正当理由，而这些理由不仅仅是“我们的商业利益正在受损”？或者说这种看法太冷嘲热讽了？我认为这确实太冷嘲热讽了，是的。我认为他们肯定想要捍卫自己的物质利益，但我认为我并不想暗示，
there's anything insincere when they protested that their liberties were being trampled on by the British government. Right. And British response to the Boston Tea Party, does it make these feelings kind of worse, throwing petrol on the fire? It really does. I mean, this is the point. And the reason why the Boston Tea Party, the destruction of the tea as it was known at the time, is rightly remembered as a key staging post to revolution is because the because of the reaction in london was so severe and this is where we're getting to the point by 1774 where dominic asked me at the end of the first episode if i thought by 1770 independence was inevitable and i said no I didn't think it was
当他们抗议自己的自由正被英国政府践踏时，其中有任何不真诚的成分。没错。而英国对波士顿倾茶事件的反应，是否让这种情绪变得更糟糕、如同火上浇油？确实如此。我的意思是，这就是关键所在。为什么波士顿倾茶事件（当时被称为倾茶事件）被正确地铭记为通往革命的关键驿站，原因就在于伦敦方面的反应如此强烈。正因如此，到了1774年，也就是多米尼克在第一集结尾问我，我是否认为到1770年独立是不可避免的，而我说不，我不认为是这样的。
by 1774 we're getting we're getting into stickier territory by the time the British government hears about the destruction of the tea and responds to it with a series of quite punitive pieces of legislation and these are the coercive acts as they're called or the America what's the American school the intolerable acts and these were Acts. And when we come on to talk about the Declaration of Independence, you'll see that a lot of the grievances listed in the Declaration of Independence actually relate to the Coercive Acts, which of course makes it all a little bit circular. So the Declaration of Independence is castigating it by that stage, 1776, the king for actions which the British government took in response to a rebellion that was already in the British government's mind already happening.
到了1774年，我们正进入更加棘手的领域。当英国政府听到关于倾茶事件的消息，并以一系列相当具有惩罚性的立法作出回应时——这些就是所谓的“强制法案”，或者用美洲的话来说叫什么？美洲的说法是“不可容忍法案”。这些都是法案。当我们接下来谈论《独立宣言》时，你会发现《独立宣言》中列出的许多怨言实际上都与“强制法案”有关，当然这让事情变得有点循环论证了。所以《独立宣言》在那个阶段（1776年）痛斥国王所采取的行动，而这些行动其实是英国政府为了应对英国政府心中已经爆发的叛乱而做出的反应。
But the coercive acts included a bill which overrode the Massachusetts Bay Charter, brought the colony under the direct control of London, limited town meetings. I mean, these are very serious things. I mean, this really is a quite extreme set of actions. It wasn't completely unprecedented, and the British government had interfered in colonial charters back in the past, but in this context... But had they done anything similar to, say, to rebellions within Britain itself? Or is this seen as being something that is purely colonial? Policymakers in London were, of course, always thinking about the rebellion that appeared to be brewing in at least some of the colonies in North America in the context of the British
但强制法案包括一项推翻马萨诸塞湾特许状的法案，该法案将该殖民地置于伦敦的直接控制之下，并限制了镇民大会。我的意思是，这些都是非常严重的事情。我的意思是，这确实是一套相当极端的行动。这并不是完全史无前例的，英国政府过去也曾干涉过殖民地的特许状，但在这种背景下……但他们是否曾对英国本土的叛乱采取过类似的做法？或者这被视为纯粹是殖民地的事务？伦敦的决策者们当然一直在考虑，在更广泛的英国
Empire more widely. And weapons were being stockpiled in Ireland at the same time. And part of the worry on the part of the British government was the classic kind of domino theory. If we let these colonies go, who will be next? And that's what they kept on saying. And Ireland was expected to be next. Ireland, of course, had its own parliament at this point in Dublin. So there were lots of parallels between the government of Ireland and the government of
帝国的背景下，北美至少某些殖民地似乎正在酝酿的叛乱。与此同时，爱尔兰也在囤积武器。英国政府担忧的一部分是典型的多米诺骨牌理论。如果我们放走这些殖民地，下一个会是谁？这就是他们不断在说的话。而爱尔兰预计将是下一个。当然，爱尔兰当时在都柏林有自己的议会。因此，爱尔兰政府与殖民地政府之间有很多相似之处。
the colonies. And in fact, Charles Townsend, the Chancellor of the Exchequer, who unwisely levied a lot of duties on the American colonies, which had since been repealed, his brother was the Lord Lieutenant of Ireland at the same time. So the two Townsend brothers were both involved at the same moment in trying to deal with what seemed at points to be very parallel colonial challenges. The most popular brothers in the british empire but actually you know we did a series about about the history of ireland adam and we yeah ended up by doing the easter rising with paul rouse and and there are so many
事实上，财政大臣查尔斯·唐森德——他不明智地对美洲殖民地征收了大量关税，此后这些关税已被废除——他的兄弟当时正是爱尔兰总督。因此，唐森德兄弟俩在同一时刻都卷入了试图应对似乎在某些方面非常相似的殖民地挑战的行动中。大英帝国最受欢迎的兄弟。但事实上，你知道的，我们做过一系关于爱尔兰历史的节目，亚当，我们……最后和保罗·劳斯一起做了一集关于复活节起义的节目。在那段历史中、在这段历史中有如此之多的
things in that story in this story that there are so many interesting resonances yeah so there are moments of what you might see as in sort of imperial metropolitan overreaction. Yeah. But the people who are administering that say, well, we have no choice because if we don't do this, we will look weak. And so Lord North actually says after the Boston Tea Party, we are now to establish our authority or give it up entirely. Whatever may be the consequence, we must risk something because if we do not, all is over.
共鸣，有如此之多的有趣呼应。是的，所以会有一些你可能认为是某种帝国大都市过度反应的时刻。是的。但那些执行政策的人说：“好吧，我们别无选择，因为如果我们不这样做，我们就会显得软弱。”因此，诺斯勋爵在波士顿倾茶事件后实际上说道：“我们现在必须确立我们的权威，或者彻底放弃它。无论结果如何，我们都必须冒一些险，因为如果我们不这样做，一切就都完了。”
I mean, he basically is the prisoner of events he says like i can't just say oh we threw our tea in the harbor this colossal because the 10th is it 10 000 pounds did you say which is an enormous sum of money yeah i mean a massive sum of money he can't say oh lads that was that was bad behavior but but you know steady on yeah forgive and forget i mean he obviously thinks well we absolutely have to do something and i suppose it goes back to the point that you would make in the first episode the american colonists are not the most valuable colonists to the british so they think we have to make an example in these kind of these colonies now because if this spreads to more
我的意思是，他基本上成了事件的囚徒。他说：“我不能只是说，哦，我们把茶扔进港口了，这太巨大了——因为那笔钱是多少？是1万英镑吗？你刚才说是1万英镑，这是一笔巨款。是的，我的意思是，这是一笔巨额资金。他不能说，哦，伙计们，那行为太糟糕了，但是呢，稳住，原谅并忘记吧。”我的意思是，他显然认为，好吧，我们绝对必须做点什么。我想这可以追溯到你在第一集里提出的观点：美洲殖民地对英国人来说并不是最有价值的殖民地，所以他们认为，我们必须现在在这些殖民地树立一个榜样，因为如果这蔓延到更有价值的殖民地，那将是灾难性的。难道这基本上不是他们的立场吗？
valuable colonies then that would be disastrous. Isn't that basically their position? Yes, yes, I think it is. And there's a, I mean, for Lord North, who had previously not been a hardliner particularly at all, and indeed for the King, who backs Lord North and kind of keeps on stopping him trying to resign, as poor old Lord North keeps on trying to do throughout the war in the coming years. And the King has up until this point not been a hardliner at all. But the Boston Tea Party tips them both into saying, exactly as you just said, Dominic,
是的，是的，我认为是的。而且——我的意思是，对于诺斯勋爵来说（他以前并不是一个特别强硬的人），甚至对于国王来说（他支持诺斯勋爵，并不断阻止他试图辞职——在接下来的几年战争中，可怜的诺斯勋爵一直在试图辞职），直到这个时间点，国王也一直根本不是一个强硬派。但波士顿倾茶事件促使他们两人都说，正如你刚才所说的那样，多米尼克，
sorry, this is actually, we can't put up with this. Because at stake here is this fundamental issue of sovereignty. Lord North actually says in the House of Commons, when the destruction of the tea becomes known, that the Americans are acting as if they were an independent empire. And they're not. But he's put his finger on it there. They are acting as if they're an independent state. And they are also saying that. So Thomas Jefferson comes into the story at this point, because he writes his summary view of the rights of British America in 1774, in which he basically says, Jefferson says, the colonies are already independent in practice. So he's still referring to them as British Americans, even at this point.
抱歉，这实际上是——我们不能再忍受了。因为这里危及的是主权这个根本问题。当倾茶事件广为人知时，诺斯勋爵实际上在下议院表示，美国人的行径就好像他们是一个独立的帝国一样。然而他们并不是。但他一针见血地指出了这一点。他们的行径确实就像是一个独立的国家。而且他们也在这样说。所以托马斯·杰斐逊在这个时候进入了故事，因为他在1774年写下了他的《对不列颠美洲权利的概要视察》，在其中他基本上说道——杰斐逊说，殖民地在实践中已经独立了。所以即使在这个时候，他仍然称他们为不列颠美国人。
Yes, still referring to the British Americans. And he's not, Jefferson is not at this point arguing directly for independence. He's saying we've already got independence. Yeah, we've got it.'ve got it. We've always had it. Well, that's not the view in London. Jefferson's vision of empire, as late as 1774, appears to be this very loose confederation under the auspices of the British monarchy, in which there are self-governing dominions. Of course, that is, in fact, a model that the British Empire later adopts and is to adopt, for example, in Canada. At various points late in the war in 1770, 1880, pretty much what the British government offer the Americans. By then it's too late. But in 1774, that's what they are effectively asking for.
是的，仍然称他们为不列颠美国人。而且他——杰斐逊在这个时候并没有直接为主权独立进行辩论。他说的是我们已经独立了。是的，我们得到了。我们一直都拥有它。好吧，伦敦可不是这么看的。直到1774年，杰斐逊对帝国的构想似乎仍然是在英国君主制的庇护下进行的一种非常松散的联邦，其中包含自治领地。当然，这实际上是英国后来采纳并准备采纳的一种模式，例如在加拿大。在战争后期的不同时间点，即1770年、1880年，这几乎就是英国政府向美国人提供的方案。到那时已经太晚了。但在1774年，这正是他们实际上在要求的。
Can I just ask about people like Jefferson, Adams, and so on, Sam Adams, Benjamin Franklin. If you had said to them, okay, point taken, no representation, no taxation, Parliament is not sovereign over you, you have your independence. However, how are you going to defend yourselves against the Native Americans and maybe the Spanish or if the French come back. What's your plan for that? Who's going to pay for the troops? How would they have answered that question? They would have said, we'll do it ourselves. Leave it to us. We are free, self-governing entities. Is it at this point that the idea of American colonists as ancient Romans, kind of hardy farmers who till the land and then take up their weapons to defend their farmsteads. Is this starting to kick in at this point?
我能问一下关于杰斐逊、亚当斯等人，萨缪尔·亚当斯、本杰明·富兰克林这样的人吗？如果你对他们说：“好吧，你的观点我接受了，没有代表就没有纳税，议会对你们没有主权，你们拥有独立地位。然而，你们将如何保护自己免受美洲原住民的攻击，或许还有西班牙人，或者如果法国人卷土重来呢？你们的计划是什么？谁来为军队付钱？”他们会如何回答这个问题？他们会说：“我们自己来。交给我们吧。我们是自由的、自治的实体。”也就是在这个时候，将美洲殖民地视为古代罗马人——那种耕作土地、然后拿起武器保卫自己农庄的坚韧农民——这种想法开始萌芽了吗？
The idea that America is somehow nobler, purer, hasn't been corrupted by the poison of empire and luxury? Yes, definitely. And they've got recent experience. They've got plenty of experience. I mean, the militia, the colonial militias have been very active for many decades, and they're used to fighting their own wars against Native Americans. And it's certainly true that in the Seven Years' War, they had to do so alongside regiments of British Redcoats. And there was a lot of tension between the two. But there was really, you know, during the war, there was this sense, even then, a lot of people in the colonies saying, look, we don't need you. We don't need your regiments. We can deal with this ourselves. It wasn't actually true, but there was a lot of feeling. Okay. So to turn that on its head, why did the British government not say, okay, well, you, you know, we'll get rid of all the 10,000 troops that we've got. You look after, you know, you look after yourselves. We subcontract Defence for America to Americans. I think that's a really good question, Tom.
认为美洲在某种程度上更加高贵、更加纯洁、没有受到帝国和奢侈之毒腐蚀的想法？是的，绝对是的。而且他们有最近的经验。他们有丰富的经验。我的意思是，民兵，殖民地的民兵已经活跃了数十年，他们习惯于为自己与美洲原住民作战。而且确实在七年战争期间，他们不得不与英国红衫军团并肩作战。两者之间存在着很大的紧张关系。但确实，你知道的，在战争期间，甚至在那时，殖民地的许多人就有一种感觉：“看，我们不需要你们。我们不需要你们的军团。我们自己就能处理好这件事。”虽然这其实并不是真的，但当时确实有这种感觉。好吧。反过来讲，为什么英国政府不这样说：“好吧，你知道的，我们会撤掉我们所有的1万名军队。你们自己照顾好自己。我们将美洲的防务外包给美国人。”我认为这是一个非常好的问题，汤姆。
And the thing is, in the end, the British government, faced with the prospect of losing the 13 colonies, do pretty much say that. But by then it's too late. I think it would have been pretty hard for the British government to go quite as far as saying, well, you look after your own defence, given the kind of ongoing anxiety about a resurgence of French and Spanish influence and the other ways in which left to their own devices, the
问题在于，最终英国政府在面临失去13个殖民地的前景时，确实差不多是这么说的。但到那时已经太晚了。我想英国政府当时很难走得那么远，直接说“好吧，你们自己照顾自己的防务”，考虑到人们对法国和西班牙影响力复苏的持续焦虑，以及如果任由殖民地自行其是，
colonists would have provoked wars with indigenous peoples, which inevitably would have drawn in the British taxpayer in one form or another, so long as they were part of the British empire. But that sentiment is there. Look, just let them get on with it. And there are, as I've said, there are people in the House of Commons even who are saying that. be tamed in the the way that americans see it is um the quebec act which basically gives freedom of religion to french catholics but it also extends the the boundaries of quebec kind of further south into new england and so you have um people who uh who is it it's um joseph reed who is a philadelphia lawyer who who says that this act is bringing down the Canadians and savages upon the English colonies. And he describes it as odious and dreadful and cruel and unnatural.
他们必然会挑起与原住民的战争，而只要他们还是大英帝国的一部分，这些战争不可避免地会以这样或那样的方式把英国纳税人拖下水。但这种情绪是存在的。看，随他们去吧。正如我所说，下议院里甚至都有人这么说。被驯服——美洲人眼中的方式是《魁北克法案》，它基本上赋予了法国天主教徒宗教自由，但它也将魁北克的边界进一步向南延伸到了新英格兰。于是你们有——是谁来着？是约瑟夫·里德，他是一位费城律师，他说这项法案正在把加拿大人和野蛮人引向英国殖民地。他将其描述为可憎的、可怕的、残酷的且非自然的。
The coercive acts, the Massachusetts Government Act and the Administration of Justice Act, which meant that the trials of royal officials could take place elsewhere, and the Boston Port Act, which closed the port of Boston, those are the coercive acts. But when the Americans referred to the intolerable acts, they added to that list the Quebec Act. It's difficult to underestimate the importance of anti-Catholicism in generating this sense of antagonism, this notion that you would privilege. I mean, they talked about establishing the Catholic religion, which was an overstatement. That wasn't actually what the Quebec Act did, but it did allow the Catholic Church to collect tithes. It was an essential, pragmatic piece of good government from London because you had this fairly large population of French Catholics. And it was an extremely successful piece of
强制法案——《马萨诸塞政府法》和《司法管理法》（这意味着皇家官员的审判可以在其他地方进行），以及关闭波士顿港的《波士顿港口法》——这些就是强制法案。但当美国人提到“不可容忍法案”时，他们在名单上加上了《魁北克法案》。很难低估反天主教情绪在产生这种敌对感、这种认为你给予特权的想法方面的重要性。我的意思是，他们谈到了确立天主教地位，这是一种夸大其词。这其实并不是《魁北克法案》所做的事情，但它确实允许天主教教会征收什一税。这是伦敦方面一项必不可少的、务实的良政措施，因为当时有相当大一部分法国天主教人口。这也是一项极其成功的
legislation as well because there was no significant revolt. I was about to say, it was incredible. Quebec's still there. I mean, Quebec is still loyal. Exactly. So it was tremendously successful, the Quebec Act of 1774. But the Americans, as you rightly say, Tom, saw it as evidence of the complete corruption of the British government, and the Catholicization of the British government. And Paul Revere, the illustrator who we talked about in the last episode, who's probably most famous, if people have seen any image by him, it's probably the one of the Boston Massacre, so-called, of the British Red Streets opening fire. But he also published a sort of cartoon called The Miter Minuet, which is a kind of
立法，因为当时并没有爆发任何重大的起义。我正要说呢，这太不可思议了。魁北克依然存在。我的意思是，魁北克依然忠诚。完全正确。所以1774年的《魁北克法案》取得了巨大的成功。但正如你正确指出的那样，汤姆，美国人将其视为英国政府彻底腐败以及英国政府天主教化的证据。保罗·里尔——我们在上一集里谈到过的那个插画家，他可能最为人所知——如果人们看过他的任何图像，那可能就是那幅被称为“波士顿惨案”的英国红衫军开火的画作。但他还发表了一幅名为《米特尔小步舞曲》的漫画，这是一种
anti-Catholic depiction of Church of England bishops in kind of conclave, in this kind of sinister witch-like conclave. So he was busy spreading this idea that Catholicism was coming alongside the alleged authoritarianism that had completely corrupted English liberty. And that is pure 1630s, 1640s kind of propaganda, isn't it? I mean, it's almost preserved in aspic. But also this idea that the British are secretly plotting to bring in Native Americans against them. I mean, it's exactly the language of the parliamentarians
反天主教的描绘，展现了英国国教主教们在某种秘密会议中，进行着这种阴险的、像女巫一样的秘密会议。因此，他一直在积极传播这样一种想法：天主教正在伴随着彻底腐蚀了英国自由的所谓专制主义一同袭来。这完全是1630年代、1640年代的那种宣传，对吧？我的意思是，它几乎像是在福尔马林中被完美保存了下来。还有英国人在秘密密谋调遣美洲原住民来对付他们的这种想法。我的意思是，这简直就是议会派在英国内战中
about the Irish in the English Civil War. And the territorial issue as well, Tom, that you rightly say. So the other thing the Quebec Act did was to greatly expand the boundaries of the province of Quebec in a way that, so it meant that they, especially the New Englanders, but also the New Yorkers and the Pennsylvanians felt that they were being hemmed in yet again by this unholy alliance of Catholics and Native Americans. So just before we go to the break, Adam, let's end this half with the,
针对爱尔兰人的言论。还有领土问题，汤姆，正如你所正确指出的。所以《魁北克法案》做的另一件事，就是大幅扩大了魁北克省的边界，以至于——这意味着他们，尤其是新英格兰人，还有纽约人和宾夕法尼亚人，感到自己再次被天主教徒和美洲原住民这个万恶的同盟给包围了。所以在我们进入中场休息之前，亚当，让我们用这样一个画面来结束前半集：
they're all agitated, they're in a terrible lather about all of these things. Catholicism, Indians, tea, taxes. And they call for a congress of representatives from all across the colonies, which becomes known as the First Continental Congress, which meets the following September, 1774, in Philadelphia. I think every colony sends representatives, but Georgia, is that right? Because Georgia is the smallest, the newest, and the most loyal. Have I got that right?
他们全都群情激昂，为所有这些事情气急败坏。天主教、印第安人、茶叶、税收。他们呼吁召开一个由来自所有殖民地的代表组成的会议，这就是后来为人所知的“第一届大陆会议”，它于第二年的1774年9月在费城召开。我记得除了佐治亚州之外，每个殖民地都派出了代表，对吗？因为佐治亚州是最小、最新也是最忠诚的。我没记错吧？
Furthest away as well. Furthest away. Okay. And what does the Continental Congress do? What's the point of it? It's significant that it's called the Continental Congress, by the way, as well. There had been a stamp act Congress, but Continental Congress is pretty aspirational, because the whole continent is supposedly being represented. It meets to coordinate the colony's response to the intolerable acts. Okay, very good. So we end on this extraordinary cliffhanger, as Adam is going to tell us what the Continental Congress did. Don't go away. It's a big discussion, Dominic.
而且也是距离最远的。距离最远。好的。那么大陆会议做了什么？它的意义何在？顺便说一句，“大陆会议”这个名字本身就意味深长。之前曾有过《印花税法》会议，但“大陆会议”具有很高的宏大抱负，因为整个大陆据称都得到了代表。它召开的目的是为了协调殖民地对不可容忍法案的反应。好的，非常好。因此我们在这样一个非凡的悬念中结束前半场，接下来亚当将告诉我们大陆会议做了什么。不要走开。这是一场宏大的讨论，多米尼克。
We've never had a more thrilling cliffhanger in the history of the Rest is History. So we'll see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes,
我们从未在《历史的余烬》历史上经历过如此惊心动魄的悬念。所以我们在中场休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，向大家展示它的运作方式。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History, one of the most thrilling cliffhangers we have ever known adam smith is going to tell us what the continental congress did and what it was all about adam what a build-up take it away please it's really exciting this they adopted the suffolk resolves Whoa. Get in. So tell us about a series of resolutions that were drawn up by Suffolk County, Massachusetts, which I think is the county that includes Boston, condemning the intolerable acts, encouraging non-importation, pledging no obedience to the Massachusetts Government Act, which had closed all the courts, and urged colonists to stockpile weapons. They started contacting ammunition
以及抢先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，这是我们经历过的最惊心动魄的悬念之一，亚当·史密斯将为我们讲述大陆会议究竟做了什么以及这一切是怎么回事。亚当，这个铺垫太棒了，请开始吧！这真的很令人兴奋。他们通过了《萨福克决议》。哇。干得漂亮。给我们讲讲马萨诸塞州萨福克郡（我想就是包含波士顿那个郡）起草的一系列决议吧，它们谴责了不可容忍法案，鼓励抵制进口，誓言不服从关闭了所有法院的《马萨诸塞政府法》，并敦促殖民地囤积武器。他们开始联系荷兰和西班牙的弹药
traders in Holland and Spain and started bringing weapons in. In other words, it was the moment when the colonists started formally and explicitly preparing for armed resistance. So John Adams agrees with you. He thinks this was a tremendous moment as well, because he called it one of the happiest days of my life. I know. My lover. And actually, Gordon Wood, in his short account of the American Revolution,
商人，并开始运进武器。换句话说，那是殖民地开始正式且明确地为武装抵抗做准备的时刻。所以约翰·亚当斯同意你的看法。他也认为这是一个了不起的时刻，因为他称之为“我生命中最快乐的日子之一”。我知道。我的挚爱。事实上，戈登·伍德在其关于美国革命的简短记述中
he also says this is the point at which there is nothing the British could have done. So what do the British do? After the Continental Congress, my rights in saying there are all kinds of vigilante groups and local committees and many Gordon Woods description, he says people are going around tarring and feathering loyalists if they are not, you know, there's a kind of violence and intimidation into the story in a really significant way from this point onwards. How much do know there's a kind of violence and intimidation into the story in a really significant way from this point onwards how much do you agree that a lot of this stuff is actually a lot of that people are settling local grievances and things and there's all kinds of i don't know local bigwigs who have feuded for years and now this is their chance to kind
他同时还指出，这也是英国人无论如何也无力回天的时刻。那么英国人做了什么？在大陆会议之后，如戈登·伍德所描述的那样，到处都是各种义警团和地方委员会。他说，人们开始四处给保王派涂柏油、粘羽毛，如果你不这么做的话……你知道，从这个时间点开始，暴力和恐吓以一种非常显著的方式进入了历史叙事。你认为从这个时间点开始，很大程度上其实是人们在借机清算地方宿怨，各种积怨多年的地方权贵终于等到了互相拆台的机会，这种情况到底占了多大比重？
of outflank each other and how much is that driving things there's a lot of that and it's an old it's an old historian more than 100 years ago now. He said the issue of the American Revolution was not so much who should rule, but who should rule at home. And so this is a highly fragmented society in lots of ways across race and ethnic boundaries and obviously class. And there are an awful lot of tensions and issues that are being worked out in the context of this crisis, made worse by the fact
这种现象其实占了很大比重，而且早在一百多年前就有历史学家指出过这一点。他曾说过，美国革命的核心问题与其说是“谁来统治”，不如说是“谁在本地统治”。因此，这是一个在种族、族裔边界以及阶层上极其破碎的社会。在这场危机中，有大量的紧张局势和问题正在得到解决，而以下这个事实使情况变得更加糟糕：
that you've closed, in places like Massachusetts, you've closed all the courts. Royal governments are ceasing to function across the 13 colonies by the end of 1774, which is why this really has now reached a point where it's difficult. It's really hard to see how it could have been de-escalated effectively, especially given the fact that in London, even some of those people like Isaac Barré and Edmund Burke, who had been the friends of America, had supported the coercive acts. Even they had said, yeah, we cannot have this destruction of the tea. We've got to do something. We've got to make a stand. So the Americans were losing their friends in London at the same time that theicans were losing their friends in london at the same time that the british were losing their friends in america but adam in the first episode you talked about how in london there
在马萨诸塞等地方，所有的法庭都被关闭了。到1774年底，英国皇室在13个殖民地的政府已经停止运转，这就是为什么局势发展到了现在这个极其棘手的地步。局势几乎已经不可能再被有效地缓和下来，特别是考虑到在伦敦，哪怕是像艾萨克·巴雷和埃德蒙·伯克这样曾经的美国之友、曾经支持过《强制法案》的人，就连他们也表示：是的，我们绝不能容忍毁茶之举。我们必须采取行动，必须表明立场。因此，当英国人正在失去他们在美洲的朋友时，美国人也正在失去他们在伦敦的朋友。但亚当，你在第一集里讲过，在伦敦，
is a sense that the peculiar kind of hotbed of rebellion in north america is new england and that perhaps it you know if you could kind of ring fence that off then you could stop the flames of rebellion spreading. And is that why in February 1775, it's specifically Massachusetts that is declared to be in rebellion? Yes. They still think in London that Massachusetts is the real problem. If you can cauterize the rebellion in Massachusetts, there is an underlying level of loyalism across the colonies which will come to the fore as long as you can isolate the rebels. And is that not true, Adam? Fundamentally, it isn't true. At least it's not nearly as true as they need it to be for their strategy to work. John Adams famously, and he's still always quoted as saying this, John Adams later says that he thinks the colonial population,
人们普遍认为北美叛乱的核心温床是新英格兰，也许只要把那个地方隔离起来，就能阻止叛乱的星星之火继续蔓延。这是否就是为什么在1775年2月，英国专门宣布马萨诸塞处于叛乱状态？是的。伦敦方面依然认为马萨诸塞才是真正的症结所在。如果你能将马萨诸塞的叛乱遏制并扑灭，那么在各个殖民地中，依然存在着一股潜在的保王主义力量，只要你能孤立叛军，这股力量就会浮出水面。亚当，难道事实并非如此吗？从根本上讲，事实并非如此。至少，它远没有达到他们的战略所需要的那么真实。约翰·亚当斯有一句名言——至今仍常被引用，他后来声称，他认为殖民地的人口中，
a third of them were loyalists, a third of them were patriots, and a third couldn't decide. I think that's, in a way, that's slightly self-serving to him. It makes the patriots' achievement seem greater. I mean, it may be that a third of the population in some colonies in the South remained actively loyal to the king. And if you include enslaved people in the loyal population, then you probably do get to about a third. But in Massachusetts, you struggle to find evidence that a third of the white population of Massachusetts were loyal in the sense of actively maintaining their loyalty to the royal government of Massachusetts by 1774. And so in Massachusetts, the governor of Massachusetts is also the commander-in-chief of all the British forces in North America, a man called Thomas Gage.
三分之一是保王派，三分之一是爱国者，还有三分之一摇摆不定。我认为，在某种程度上，这种说法对他自己有点私心，它让爱国者们的成就显得更加伟大。我的意思是，在南部的一些殖民地，可能确实有三分之一的人口对国王保持着积极的忠诚；如果你把被奴役的人口也算进忠诚派里，那大概确实能达到三分之一。但在马萨诸塞，你很难找到证据证明，到1774年时，马萨诸塞白人人口中有三分之一在“积极维护对马萨诸塞皇家政府的忠诚”这种意义上是保王派。因此在马萨诸塞，马萨诸塞的总督同时也是英国在北美所有部队的最高指挥官，他就是托马斯·盖奇。
Becomes so, yes. Thomas Gage, yes. And so he's a veteran of the Seven Years' War. He's fought in America. Very brave man, but is starting to be criticized as, quote unquote, an old woman. Yes. Weak. quote, an old woman. Yes, weak. It's seen as being weak. And so there's a kind of agitation on the part of the British imperial authorities for a bit of action, you know, show the rebels a bit of stick. Yeah. So what happens next? Gage is the man who says, well, the first thing you've got to do quite logically is to gather up the rebels' weapons.
成了这样，是的。托马斯·盖奇，没错。所以他是七年战争的老兵，曾在美洲作战。这是一个非常勇敢的人，但开始被人贬低为所谓的“老太婆”。是的，软弱。所谓的“老太婆”。是的，软弱。他被视为软弱无能。因此，英国帝国当局内部有一种采取果断行动的冲动，你知道，给叛军一点颜色看看。是的。那接下来发生了什么？盖奇这个人认为，很符合逻辑的第一步就是收缴叛军的武器。
And so there's an armaments depot outside of Boston and Cambridge, which the British regulars seize. And then they march off to Lexington and Concord. And this is the moment when it all starts. And so this is the famous thing where Paul Revere, who we've talked about before, is supposed to go galloping off shouting, the British are coming. Although he wouldn't have said the British are coming because at this point, still, the rebels see themselves as British as well, still at that point, right? They do. But I think probably by this point, I don't know whether he literally said the British are coming, but I think by this point, the British was coming to be associated with the regular troops in Boston. And that was what made
于是，在波士顿和剑桥郊外有一个军火库，英国正规军占领了那里。随后，他们向列克星敦和康科德进发。这就是一切拉开序幕的时刻。这也是那个著名的历史桥段：我们之前提到过的保罗·里弗尔骑马飞奔，大喊着“英国人来了”。尽管他当时绝不会说“英国人来了”，因为直到此时此刻，叛军仍然把自己也视为英国人，在那个时间点依然如此，对吧？他们的确如此。不过我想，到了这个时候——我不知道他是不是真的喊了“英国人来了”，但我觉得到了这个时候，“英国人”这个词已经开始用来指代波士顿的正规军了。正是这一点让
Boston a very particular case because the British had become aliens within the city because of the presence of the regular troops but that's you know midnight ride of listen my children and you shall hear the midnight ride of paul revere i mean this is that's the longfellow poem isn't it from i think 1861 but it becomes i think it's probably still part of you know american american folklore um this is when the first shots were fired. The shot heard around the world. The shot heard around the world. I think that's Emerson, isn't it, who called it that?
波士顿成了一个非常特殊的案例，因为由于正规军的存在，英国人在城里已经变成了异类。但这也就是朗费罗那首诗里写的“听我的孩子，你们将听到保罗·里弗尔的午夜策马”……我的意思是，那是朗费罗大约在1861年写的诗，对吧？但它后来——我想它大概仍然是美国民间传说的一部分……这就是第一枪打响的时刻。震惊世界的枪声。震惊世界的枪声。我想那是爱默生说的吧，是哪个叫爱默生的人这么称呼的？
So Concord is about 17 miles from Boston. They've marched out, General Gage is meant to get these guns, and they're met first on the common Lexington, I think. That's where the shot happens. It's not at Concord. It's at Lexington. Yeah. And there's about 70 militia men. And it's all, the funny thing about all of these encounters,
康科德距离波士顿大约有17英里。英军行军出城，盖奇将军原本是要去收缴这些枪械，结果他们首先在列克星敦的公地遇到了民兵。枪击事件就是在那发生的，不是在康科德，而是在列克星敦。是的。当时大概有70名民兵。所有这些冲突最滑稽的地方在于，
so I was reading up about this and the Seven Years' War, which had proceeded. So in the Seven Years' War in Europe, there were these colossal battles with kind of, you know, you can see them on Wikipedia or something. It'll say sort of Prussian troop strength, 60,000 men. And these, in inverted commas, battles, there's kind of three men and a dog. I mean, they're kind of 70 militia men here, 100 redcoats there.
我当时在查阅相关资料时看到，之前进行的是七年战争。在欧洲的七年战争中，发生过那种宏大无比的战役，你可以在维基百科或者其他地方看到，上面会写着普鲁士军队兵力6万人之类的信息。然而这些被加上引号的“大战”，实际上只有三个人加一条狗。我的意思是，这里大概有70名民兵，那里有100名红衫军。
They're all, it's all a bit, I mean, there have been football hooligan fights that have been bigger than this, haven't there? Right. But in the Seven Years' War, and indeed in football hooligan fights, people want to get stuck in. And there is a sense even now that neither side really wants to engage. So I was reading Woody Holton's book, Liberty is Sweet. And he says of the Battle of Lexington that it would not have occurred if the officers leading the British column had known that the colonists were determined not to be the aggressors. Because they are anxious about
这整件事……我的意思是，有些足球流氓斗殴的规模都比这大，对吧？没错。但在七年战争中，以及在足球流氓的斗殴中，人们都是渴望大干一场的。然而直到现在，人们依然有一种感觉，那就是双方其实都不想真正开战。我当时在读伍迪·霍尔顿的书《自由是甜的》，他关于列克星敦战役写道，如果率领英国军队纵队的军官们早知道殖民地民兵决心不当侵略者的话，这场战役根本就不会发生。因为英军担心
exposing their flank. You never expose your flank. But it would have been fine for the British to do that. They're confronted by the rebels. They need to turn around. They can't risk doing that because they're afraid that the rebels will shoot. The rebels aren't going to shoot because they don't want to fight. And so the British then fire at the rebels. So it's all a bit of a shambles. And then they go on to Concord, which is further on from Lexington, I think.
暴露自己的侧翼。你绝不能暴露侧翼。但对英国人来说，那样做其实也无妨。他们遭到了叛军的对峙，需要掉头撤退，但他们又不敢冒这个险，因为害怕叛军会开枪。而叛军又不想开枪，因为他们不想打仗。结果呢，英国人反而向叛军开枪了。所以这一切简直是一团糟。然后他们继续前往康科德，我想那是在列克星敦更远的地方。
It's in Adam. And there's a bridge. Some of them go across a bridge. And it's all a bit more shouting and scuffling and firing and this is where the first british soldiers get shot by yeah by rebels and then the british fall back so i read that there are militiamen new england militiamen sort of firing at them as they as they fall back towards boston so these militiamen adam have they always they always been there? Have they been sort of drummed up especially for the revolutionary crisis or are they part of colonial life? They're part of colonial life, but the militia units have been drilling and preparing in the preceding couple of years for this kind of conflict. Right. And so by the end of the day, 65 British, I think 50 Americans, if Gordon Wood is right, which I'm sure he is, are dead.
在亚当那边。那里有一桥梁。其中一些人穿过了一桥梁。然后又是更多的叫喊、推搡和开火，正是在这里，第一批英国士兵被叛军开枪击中了。随后英国军队开始撤退。我读到过，有民兵——新英格兰民兵在他们撤回波士顿的途中一路向他们开枪射击。亚当，这些民兵以前就在那里吗？他们是为了革命危机而专门拼凑起来的，还是他们本来就是殖民生活的一部分？他们是殖民生活的一部分，不过在过去的几年里，民兵部队一直在为这种冲突进行钻研和备战。没错。就这样，到了那天结束时，根据戈登·伍德的说法——我相信他的数据没错，有65名英国人、大约50名美国人丧生。
And the British go back to Boston and they basically now realize we are in enemy territory. We kind of hold up in the city. And the countryside has risen. The place is teeming with sort of militiamen and whatnot. And I guess it's not long after that is about a month after that that we have the second continental congress so the first one was very exciting and the second one is more exciting they're still talking about loyalties to the king though incredibly yeah at this point but they decide they need an army. And why Washington as the commander, Adam?
英国人退回了波士顿，他们现在基本上意识到：我们身处敌占区了。他们只能龟缩在城里。而乡间已经全面起义，到处都是密密麻麻的民兵之类的人。我想没过多久——大约一个月后，我们就迎来了第二次大陆会议。第一次大陆会议非常激动人心，而第二次则更加激动人心。然而难以置信的是，在这个时候，他们居然还在谈论对国王的效忠。是的，但他们决定必须组建一支军队。亚当，为什么选华盛顿担任总司令？
Washington was, I think he was six foot four. He had an air of command. Whenever anyone wrote about Washington, they always said, my, he was a fine figure of a man, especially on a horse. You know, he looked the part. Although his teeth, his false teeth kind of bulge out, don't they? So he does have a problem with them, But that doesn't detract from the overall sense of dignity. As long as he keeps his mouth shut, then he's a fine figure of a man. He obviously has military experience. We talked about him already in the first episode in the Seven Years' War. Not grand military experience, but he has military experience.
华盛顿身高大概有六英尺四英寸。他有一种统帅的风范。每当有人写到华盛顿，总会说：天哪，他真是一个身材魁梧、风度翩翩的男子汉，尤其是在马背上的时候。你知道，他的外表很有大将之风。尽管他的假牙有点向外凸，对吧？所以他的牙齿确实有点问题，但这并不影响他整体的威严感。只要他闭上嘴不说话，他绝对是个风度翩翩的美男子。他显然拥有军事经验。我们在第一集里就已经谈过他参加七年战争的经历。虽然算不上什么宏大的军事经验，但他确实有军事经验。
And also he's from Virginia. And the underlying issue here, which we've sort of touched on, is that it's really difficult for these 13 colonies to come together. They're not used to doing this. They only do it in the face of extreme threat. And they're all deeply suspicious of one another. There's supposedly a moment in the Second Continental Congress where John Adams gets up to nominate someone to head the new Continental Army. And he starts talking without mentioning the name about this fine figure of a man with great military experience. And John Hancock
此外，他是弗吉尼亚人。这里隐含的问题——我们之前也稍微触及过——就是这13个殖民地要联合起来实在是太难了。他们过去根本不习惯这样做，只有在面临极端威胁时才会联合起来，而且彼此之间都怀有深深的戒备。据说在第二次大陆会议上曾有过这样一刻：约翰·亚当斯起身提名某人来统帅新的大陆军。他开始发言，在没有说出名字的情况下，描述了一个身材魁梧、拥有丰富军事经验的优秀男子。而身为国会议长、来自马萨诸塞的约翰·汉考克
from Massachusetts, the president of the Congress thinks he's going to nominate him. So he's sitting there kind of pre-expecting, expecting, expecting he's going to say me. And John Adams then said, the man is George Washington. And Hancock looks utterly furious. But the reason why John Hancock would not have been the right man for the job is nothing to do with Hancock's military prowess, but to do with the fact that he was also a New Englander. And so it was important politically, and this continued to be the case right through the war, it was important politically that different regions and interests within the colonies were balanced. So that was a lot of the reason for Washington initially. And his great strength, Washington, is that he realises they're never going to win a conventional war. That's right, isn't it? He knows that he's quite a sort of... Well, I get the sense it takes him time to appreciate that. And that actually the British
以为亚当斯要提名自己。于是他坐在那里暗自期盼、期待着、等着对方说出自己的名字。结果约翰·亚当斯随后说道：“这个人就是乔治·华盛顿。”汉考克看上去顿时暴怒。但约翰·汉考克之所以不是这份工作的合适人选，与他的军事才能毫无关系，纯粹是因为他也是个新英格兰人。因此在政治上——而且整个战争期间一直如此——保持殖民地内不同地区和利益之间的平衡至关重要。所以华盛顿最初当选很大程度上就是出于这个原因。而华盛顿最大的优势在于，他意识到他们永远不可能通过常规战来赢得胜利。对吧，是不是这样？他明白这一点，他是一个相当……嗯，我觉得他花了很长时间才真正认识到这一点。事实上，英国人
come to understand that sooner than the Americans do, for reasons that relate to the next stage of the conflict in Boston, which is the Bunker Hill campaign. But I guess the fascinating thing, Adam, I mean, Tom's point takes us to the real, for those people who are interested in military strategy and stuff, the fascinating thing here. So this is always presented as this great underdog victory.
比美国人更早明白了这一点，原因与波士顿冲突的下一个阶段有关，也就是邦克山战役。但亚当，最迷人的是——汤姆的观点把我们带向了真正引人入胜之处，对于那些对军事战略感兴趣的人来说，这里最精彩的地方在于：这场战争总是被塑造成一场伟大的弱者对强者的胜利。
The Americans, they're facing this tremendous empire. What a great triumph for the human spirit over the mechanical brutality of this massive power. But actually, the British are in a mess from the beginning, aren't they? Absolutely. Yes, it really isn't like that at all. I mean, you're absolutely right. This is the conventional analysis that the world's greatest empire, huge military force, how on earth can these plucky ragbag colonials take them on and win?
美国人面对的是这样一个庞大的帝国。这是人类精神对庞大机械暴力的伟大胜利。但事实上，英国人从一开始就陷入了一团混乱，对吧？完全正确。是的，情况根本不是那样的。我的意思是，你完全说得对。常规的分析总是说，世界上最伟大的帝国、庞大的军事力量，这些勇敢的乌合之众殖民地居民怎么可能挑战他们并赢得胜利呢？
And quite aside from the fact that they have the aid of the French, which we'll no doubt will come on to. And the challenge for the British is absolutely enormous. I mean, they've got no functional command and control structure. There's four different departments in London in charge of sending ships and supplies over. They can't rely on, what do you do about horses? You know, they initially think where you can forage and find horses in New England. That becomes very difficult because, as you just rightly say, Dominic, it's effectively enemy territory. So they bring everything across from London. It takes two months to cross the Atlantic.
撇开他们得到了法国人的援助不谈——我们毫无疑问稍后会聊到这一点，英国人面临的挑战绝对是巨大的。我的意思是，他们根本没有职能健全的指挥和控制结构。伦敦有四个不同的部门负责派遣船只和补给。他们无法依赖……比如马匹该怎么办？他们最初以为可以在新英格兰随地搜寻和找到马匹。这变得非常困难，因为正如你刚才正确指出的那样，多米尼克，这里实际上是敌占区。所以他们把所有东西都从伦敦运过来。跨越大西洋需要两个月的时间。
They have no idea what's going on. And you're a tiny, you remain a tiny, I mean, even at the height of the war, the British force is tiny, given the scale of the challenge ahead of them. There's no colonial capital, which they can easily, I mean, there is Philadelphia, but Philadelphia falls and so what, it doesn't make any difference. So a lot of the rules of warfare that the British have been used to don't apply. It's incredibly difficult. Reading the British high command in the early months and then years of the war, it reminds me of the episode, Dominic, that we did on the fall of Saigon, the challenge that faces the American military in dealing with a highly motivated guerrilla force. So there is a
他们完全不知道发生了什么。而且你们是一支微不足道的军队——甚至在战争最巅峰的时候，面对眼前的挑战规模，英军的规模依然微不足道。根本没有什么他们能轻易拿下的殖民地首都——我的意思是，费城倒是有，但费城陷落了又怎样？根本没有任何区别。因此，英国人过去习惯的很多战争规则在这里根本不适用。这实在是太困难了。阅读英国最高指挥官在战争头几个月甚至头几年的记录，多米尼克，让我想起我们做过的那期关于西贡陷落的节目，也就是美军在应对一支高度激进的游击队时所面临的挑战。当时有一位
British general is posted to America by the name of John Burgoyne, and he scans the terrain and he describes it as being full of woods, swamps, stone walls and other enclosures and hiding places. And then he draws the logical conclusion that the rebel fighters can turn every tree and bush into a kind of temporary fortress from whence when he had fired his shot with all the deliberation, coolness and certainty which hidden safety inspires, he will skip as it were to the next. So the British, even as the war is starting, understand that if the Americans do a guerrilla war, i.e. don't come and meet them in kind of full scale seven years war battles, then they're almost certainly doomed. and probably what enables the war to go on so long as i understand it is that actually it takes washington and the american high command quite a while to understand that but also isn't there a political issue adam i mean even if you do beat them so what i mean you've got to win them over to the you know this is the problem that all imperial powers yeah the hearts and minds and they use that phrase they talk about
名叫约翰·伯戈因的英国将军被派往美洲，他扫视了当地的地形，将其描述为“到处都是树林、沼泽、石墙以及其他围栏和藏身之处”。接着他得出了一个合乎逻辑的结论：叛军战士可以把每一棵树和每一处灌木都变成某种临时堡垒，当他从容、冷静、带着隐蔽安全所赋予的必胜把握开完枪后，他就可以像变戏法一样轻盈地跳到下一处隐蔽点。因此，英国人在战争刚刚打响时就已经明白，如果美国人打游击战——也就是说，不出来跟他们进行七年战争那种规模的正规大会战——那么他们几乎注定要失败。而支撑这场战争持续这么久的，据我理解，实际上是因为华盛顿和美国最高指挥官花了相当长的时间才明白这一点。但亚当，难道这里没有政治问题吗？我的意思是，就算你真的打败了他们又怎样？你必须把他们争取过来……你知道的，这就是所有帝国主义大国都面临的问题。是的，人心向背。他们确实用了这个词，他们谈论
that phrase hearts and minds the british generals politicians writing each other use that they understand they've got to win over the hearts and minds of the americans and the battle that illustrates this is the battle of bunker hill right that this involves um an attempt by the british to take back the kind of commanding heights beyond boston so it's a kind of you know it's a it requires them to a naval landing. There are various hills that have been fortified and the British do end up taking their targets, but at incredible cost. Incredible cost. Yes. I think about a third of the 3,000 British troops who were engaged in the Battle of Bunker Hill were casualties. It was obviously an unsustainable loss, relatively small force,
“人心向背”这个词。英国的将军和政治家们在互相写信时都用这个词，他们明白自己必须赢得美国民众的人心。而最能说明这一点的战役就是邦克山战役，对吧？这场战役涉及英军试图夺回波士顿以外的战略制高点，所以这是一种……这需要进行两栖登陆。有几座山丘已经被筑起工事加固，英国人最终确实夺取了他们的目标，但代价惨重。代价极其惨重。是的。我想参加邦克山战役的3000名英国士兵中，大约有三分之一伤亡。这显然是无法承受的损失，对于一支相对较小的部队来说，
but an unsustainable loss. And so it's one of those victories that actually sends the message that this is going to be really, really hard. It's a pyrrhic victory. One of the British soldiers says afterwards, never had the British army so ungenerous an enemy to oppose. What an unfair method of carrying on a war. And he complains that the
这是无法承受的损失。因此，这是一场实际上发出了“这场战争将极其、极其艰难”信号的胜利。这是一场惨胜。一名英国士兵事后说道：“英国军队从未遇到过如此不讲武德的敌人。这是多么不公平的作战方式啊！”他抱怨说，
americans have been hiding behind trees for the british bullets well this seems to be running seems very poor behavior but actually i mean again and you know just repeat in the opening months what what is striking is that this is not the strategy that the americans are taking as a matter of course well i suppose they're all feeling their way though aren't they tom they're not of course they don't they don't know how the war is going to play out. I suppose to some extent as well, have there been wars like this before where an imperial metropolis has tried to discipline a rebellious colony? I mean, obviously it's a kind of war. The Romans? I suppose the Romans, but I mean, far back in history. This kind of war that we're very familiar with now, Vietnam. But actually
美国人一直躲在树后向英国人的子弹开枪。这看起来……这似乎是极其恶劣的行为。但实际上——而且你知道的，再重申一遍，在开战的头几个月里，最让人震惊的是，这并不是美国人一开始就刻意采取的战略。好吧，我想他们当时也都在摸着石头过河，对吧，汤姆？他们当然不知道战争将会如何发展。我想在某种程度上，以前有没有过类似的战争——一个帝国都市试图整肃一个叛逆的殖民地？我的意思是，这显然是一种战争。罗马人？我想罗马人有过，但那是在遥远的历史中了。这种我们现在非常熟悉的战争，比如越南战争。但实际上，
Roman analogies are kind of bubbling around all over the place here, both in Britain and in America. It's when Gibbon is writing The Decline and Fall of the Roman Empire, and he definitely is influenced by events in America while he's doing it. But one of the reasons why the British do not adopt a Roman strategy, a Roman strategy against rebels, you would annihilate a city. You would torch it. You would enslave the inhabitants. The British, when confronted, say, with rebellions in Ireland or rebellions in India, or indeed even more so in the Caribbean, can be incredibly brutal. But they choose not to, do they? I mean, they don't kind of bring in the Royal Navy and bombard Boston because there is a feeling still that these
罗马帝国的类比当时在英国和美国到处流布。吉本正是在写作《罗马帝国衰亡史》的时候，他这样做时显然受到了美洲事件的影响。但英国人之所以没有对叛军采取罗马式的策略——按照罗马对付叛军的策略，你会直接将一座城市彻底摧毁，放火烧光它，并将居民沦为奴隶。而英国人在面对爱尔兰叛乱、印度叛乱，甚至是加勒比海地区的叛乱时，其实可以表现得极其残酷。但他们这次选择不这样做，不是吗？我的意思是，他们并没有调动皇家海军去轰炸波士顿，因为人们仍然有一种感觉，那就是
are our kith and kin. These are Protestant. These are of English stock. We can't treat them as we would treat, say, rebellious slaves in Jamaica. That's a really, really important point, Tom. That's absolutely key to the whole thing. And the Spanish in Louisiana have a face of rebellion in the 1760s, and they put it down very, very brutally. It's quite different. There were lots of options that could have been available, as you say, using the Royal Navy in a different way. If the British had really, really wanted to subdue the 13 colonies and had been prepared to divert the resources, which they clearly were never going to do, from the defense of the Sugar Islands in the Caribbean and other places, and hadn't had this sense that they were fundamentally fighting the same people, the war would have looked very
这些人是我们的同胞骨肉。他们是新教徒，是英国血统。我们不能像对待牙买加叛乱奴隶那样对待他们。这是一个非常、非常关键的观点，汤姆。这绝对是整个事件的关键所在。1760年代，路易斯安那的西班牙人也遭遇了叛乱，他们进行得极其、极其残忍地镇压。情况完全不同。正如你所说，当时其实有很多可供选择的方案，比如以不同的方式使用皇家海军。如果英国人真的、真的想要平定这13个殖民地，并且愿意从加勒比海的产糖岛屿和其他地方抽调资源——而他们显然从一开始就没打算这么做，并且如果没有那种“他们本质上是在和自己人打仗”的感觉，这场战争的面貌将会
different from how it did look. Well, in his biography of George III, which came out about a year ago, two years ago, Andrew Roberts makes the point, he says, they accused him of being a tyrant but had he been a tyrant he would have won yeah yeah yeah so bunker hill incredibly pyrrhic victory for the british and it's at that point or just shortly afterwards 23rd of august that georgia third proclaims the entire 13 colonies in open rebellion just Just before we get onto what then happens after that. So it's 13 colonies along that kind of Atlantic seaboard. Why do other colonies, so you said there were 26, why do other colonies not join them? Why only 13?
与我们所看到的截然不同。好吧，在安德罗·罗伯茨大约一年前或两年前出版的乔治三世传记中，他指出：他们指责乔治三世是个暴君，但如果他真的是个暴君，他早就赢了。对，对，对。所以邦克山战役对英国人来说是一场极其惨痛的胜利。就在那个时候，或者紧接着的8月23日，乔治三世宣告整个13个殖民地处于公开叛乱状态。在我们在接着聊接下来发生的事情之前，我想问：沿着大西洋海岸线的一共有13个殖民地，为什么其他殖民地——你刚才说一共有26个——为什么其他殖民地没有加入他们？为什么只有这13个？
So it's one of the great frustrations of the New Englanders throughout this period of tension that the Caribbean islands don't. One answer may simply be the huge preponderance of enslaved people of color in Jamaica and Barbados and Antigua, making it harder for them to talk about liberty or give me liberty or give me death. The population in South Carolina, there was a small majority of people of color, of enslaved people. In Virginia, I think it was about 40% in the 1770s. So one explanation would be that was a sort of Goldilocks number. In Virginia, you could talk about liberty without thinking that you are going to immediately be overwhelmed by a slave rebellion.
在整个紧张局势期间，新英格兰人最大的挫败感之一就是加勒比海岛屿没有加入。其中的一个答案可能很简单：牙买加、巴巴多斯和安提瓜的有色人种奴隶占了压倒性多数，这使得他们很难高谈阔论“不自由，毋宁死”。在南卡罗来纳，有色人种和被奴役人口占据了微弱的多数；在弗吉尼亚，1770年代时这一比例大约是40%。所以一种解释是，这恰好是一个“金凤花姑娘区间”（不冷不热刚刚好）。在弗吉尼亚，你可以谈论自由，而不必担心自己会立刻被奴隶起义所吞没。
So I think that may be part of the explanation, because certainly the Stamp Act and the sugar duties, not so much the sugar duties, but certainly the Stamp Act was resented in the Caribbean as well. And Canada is a different matter. I mean, the Canadian Quebec we've already talked about. I mean, there's a whole different set of issues in Quebec that the British government was separately sorting out and appeared to have done so with the Quebec Act. And then it's a matter of concentrations of population. These were long and well-established communities in most cases.
所以我想这可能是部分原因，因为印花税法案和糖税——虽然糖税没那么严重，但印花税法案在加勒比海地区同样引起了不满。至于加拿大则是另一回事。我的意思是，我们已经讨论过加拿大魁北克了。魁北克有一套完全不同的问题，英国政府当时正在单独处理，并且似乎通过《魁北克法案》妥善解决了。此外，这还涉及到人口集中的问题。在大多数情况下，这些都是长期存在且根基深厚的社区。
There was an interesting hypothetical question about whether Georgia could have needed to be included in the 13. There was a possibility that it might not have been. Georgia was a tiny, tiny place, but had a relatively new population of poor whites who wanted to be slaveholders and wanted to be more like South Carolina. So they were going to throw their lot in with their neighbours to the north. So Adam, on that topic of you talking about slaves, I mean, this in a way is a kind of key part of what is going on, because one of the things that the British obviously recognize is that people who are kept as slaves in plantations are potentially very rebellious. They know this because they have been suppressing slave rebellions
还有一个有趣的假设性问题，即佐治亚是否非得被包含在这13个殖民地之中。当时确实存在一种可能性，它可能不会被包涵进去。佐治亚是一个极小极小的地方，但那里有一群相对较新的贫穷白人人口，他们渴望成为奴隶主，渴望变得更像南卡罗来纳。所以他们最终决定与北方的邻居们同舟共济。亚当，关于你刚才谈到奴隶的话题——我的意思是，这在某种程度上其实是正在发生的事情的核心部分，因为英国人显然认识到的其中一点就是：在种植园里沦为奴隶的人具有极大的叛乱潜力。他们深知这一点，因为他们曾经残酷镇压过奴隶起义，
in Jamaica most notoriously. And so they are aware that if they can persuade slaves in plantations, say in Virginia, to rise against their owners, then this is tremendous., Lord Dunmore, issues a proclamation. And I'm aware that the exact status of this proclamation is very, very controversial at the moment in American historiography. But just to read Woody Holton again, Liberty is Sweet. He says of this declaration, which is basically an emancipation proclamation, and Holton compares it overtly to Lincoln's emancipation Proclamation almost a century later. He says of this, no other document, not even Thomas Paine's Common Sense, which kind of is the rallying cry for rebellion against the king, or the Declaration of Independence, did more than Dunmore's proclamation to convert white residents of Britain's most populous American colony to the cause of independence. In other words, the attempt by the British authorities to get slaves to rebel against their owners and to side with the British irrevocably turns white Virginians against British rule. Do you think that that's true or not? Well, just to jump in before Adam issues, what I can sort of tell from his face is going to be a withering answer. This is also a key
其中最臭名昭著的就是在牙买加。因此他们意识到，如果他们能说服种植园里的奴隶——比如在弗吉尼亚的奴隶——起来反抗他们的主人，那将是一股极其强大的力量。于是，时任弗吉尼亚总督的邓莫尔勋爵发布了一项公告。我注意到这项公告目前的具体历史定位在美洲史学界正引发非常、非常激烈的争议。但重读一下伍迪·霍尔顿的《自由是甜的》，他对这项宣言的评价是：这基本上是一份解放宣言，霍尔顿甚至公开将其与差不多一个世纪后林肯的《解放奴隶宣言》相提并论。他这样评价此事：没有任何一份文件——甚至连托马斯·潘恩的《常识》（它曾是反抗国王的战斗号角）或《独立宣言》都没有像邓莫尔公告那样，将英国人口最多的大美洲殖民地的白人居民推向独立事业。换句话说，英国当局试图让奴隶反抗主人并倒向英国一方的企图，彻底把弗吉尼亚的白人推向了反对英国统治的对立面。你认为这是真的吗？好吧，在亚当开口之前我先插一句——从他的表情我能看出他肯定会给出一番辛辣的批驳。这也是一个核心
contention, not just of Woody Holt and Tom, but of this 1619 project set up by the New York Times, which argues that the story of slavery has been slightly sort of erased from the American Revolution. And that at least in part, the American revolutionaries were motivated by a desire to preserve slavery, and they feared British abolitionism. Now, Adam, I know this is intensely controversial among historians, but since we're on the Dunmore Proclamation, how much truth is there in what Tom has just described? Well, I know Abraham Lincoln. I can't say I work with Abraham Lincoln, but I can tell you that Lord Dunmore is no Abraham Lincoln. We should say that after this, he then goes to become, I think, governor of Barbados,
争议点，不仅是伍迪·霍尔顿和汤姆的看法，也是《纽约时报》发起的那个“1619项目”的核心观点。该项目认为，奴隶制的历史在某种程度上被美国革命给抹去了，美国革命者在很大程度上是出于对维护奴隶制的渴望，并且他们恐惧英国的废奴主义。亚当，我知道这在历史学家当中极具争议，但既然我们谈到了邓莫尔公告，汤姆刚才所描述的内容到底有多少真实性？好吧，我认识亚伯拉罕·林肯。我虽然不能说我和亚伯拉罕·林肯共事过，但我可以告诉你，邓莫尔勋爵可绝不是亚伯拉罕·林肯。我们应该指出的是，在这之后，他后来去当了……我想是巴巴多斯总督，
where he notably does not free a single slave. Yes, I think that is too much of a stretch. If Woody Holton compares directly the Dunmore Proclamation with Abraham Lincoln's proclamation, I think that's just far too much of a stretch. It is definitely true. There's plenty of evidence. and Woody Holton is one of those historians who provided the evidence, that in Virginia, and no doubt also in the Carolinas, there were plenty of slaveholding white men, which is to say, you know, everybody really who we think of when we're thinking about the revolutionary leadership, who were appalled by the Dunmore Proclamation.
在那里他极其著名地没有解放哪怕一个奴隶。是的，我认为这种对比未免有些过于牵强了。如果伍迪·霍尔顿把邓莫尔公告直接拿来和亚伯拉罕·林肯的宣言相提并论，我觉得这实在是太勉强了。不过绝对可以确定的是——有大量证据表明，而且伍迪·霍尔顿正是提供这些证据的历史学家之一——在弗吉尼亚，毫无疑问也在卡罗来纳，有大量的白人奴隶主——也就是说，当我们想到革命领导层时脑海中浮现的所有人——都被邓莫尔公告吓坏了。
James Madison said, if we should be subdued, we shall fall like Achilles by the hand of one that knows that secret, meaning we have slaves. I mean, it wasn't much of a secret. But he was very overt. Edward Rutledge of South Carolina said that the Dunmore Proclamation did more effectually work an eternal separation between Great Britain and the colonies than any other expedient which could possibly have been thought of. I mean, these people were appalled, utterly appalled by what seemed to be the utter desperation of Dunmore's willingness to, I mean, they just, I mean, you talked,
詹姆斯·麦迪逊曾说：“如果我们被征服了，我们将像阿喀琉斯一样，死于一个深知我们秘密的人之手”，意思是我们拥有奴隶。我的意思是，这其实算不上什么秘密，但他表达得非常直白。南卡罗来纳的爱德华·拉特利奇表示，邓莫尔公告比任何其他可能想到的权宜之计，都更有效地促成了英国和殖民地之间永恒的决裂。我的意思是，这些人被吓坏了，彻底被邓莫尔为了达到目的而表现出的绝望姿态给吓坏了。我的意思是，你刚才……
Dominic earlier talked about how outrageous it was that the americans were firing from behind trees i mean this from the americans point of view this was this was not cricket i mean this is you did not do this you did not go there so it's both sides are cheating in the views of of the other yeah but i mean just to go back to this idea which which is much bruised by that had been much bruised by the new york times recently and so it's it's a very live issue in American public discourse at the moment. The sense in which the talk of liberty on the part of white rebels against British rule is compromised by the fact that many of the leaders of this rebellion are themselves slave
多米尼克刚才谈到美国人躲在树后开枪是多么离谱，但从美国人的角度来看，这根本不符合“板球精神”（不公平）。我的意思是，你们怎么能这么做，你们怎么能毫无底线呢？所以在彼此眼中，双方其实都在作弊。是的，但回到这个近期被《纽约时报》大肆热炒、因而在当前美国公共话语中成为一个极其炽手可热的话题的观点上：白人叛军反抗英国统治时满嘴的自由言论，却因为这场叛乱的许多领导人自己就是奴隶主而大打折扣。这可不是什么21世纪的“觉醒文化”（Wokery），当时的人们就已经指出了这一点——人们高谈阔论时的这种悖论……比如托马斯·杰斐逊，他将撰写《独立宣言》的第一稿，他曾将像他这样的弗吉尼亚人描述为被变成了一种“附属于伦敦某些商业行号的财产”，也就是说他直接说我们就像奴隶一样。但在伦敦，以及在美洲的保王派圈子里，确实有人指出这种虚伪性。是的。
owners. This is not just 21st century wokery. This is something that is pointed out at the time, the paradox of people talking about... Thomas Jefferson, for instance, who will write the first draft of the Declaration of Independence, he describes Virginians like him being turned into a species of property annexed to certain mercantile houses in london i.e directly saying we are like slaves but back in london and indeed among loyalist circles in america you have people pointing out the hypocrisy of this yeah so the most famous person who does this is samuel johnson dr johnson the great lexicographer who in a pamphlet taxation
最著名的抨击者就是塞缪尔·约翰逊，这位伟大的词典编纂家。他在1775年（大概吧，也就是这一切都在发生的时候）出版了一本名为《征税无暴政》的小册子。他在其中有一句名言：“为什么我们总能在黑奴监工中间听到最响亮的争取自由的呐喊？”正因为这句话，他似乎成了唯一一个在波士顿被当众烧纸像的英国作家。所以这些都是1775年（以及2023年）正在进行的宣传战的一部分。埃德蒙·伯克——再次引用他的话——在对议会的演讲中说，这些美国人极其过敏，他们的神经非常脆弱。我们知道这一点，原因有两个，而且都是好理由。其一是他们对自由的奉献是基于英国人的思想和原则，可能比我们现在还要笃信自由，我们应该向他们学习，因为他们就是曾经的我们。但第二个原因
no tyranny published in 1775 i think so while all this is going on. He famously says, how is it that we hear the loudest yelps for liberty among the drivers of Negroes? And as a result of that is, I think, the only British writer to have been burnt in effigy in Boston. So these are part of the propaganda war that is going on in 1775, as well as in 2023. Edmund Burke, to cite him again in a speech to Parliament, says that these Americans, they are very hypersensitive. They're really prickly. We know this. There are two reasons for this, and they're good reasons. One is that they're devoted to liberty according to English ideas on English principles, and probably more devoted to liberty than we are now. And we should learn from them because they are what we used to be. But the second reason why
他们如此敏感，是因为他们拥有奴隶。伯克指出，如果人们拥有被奴役的人口，那么那些获得自由的人反而是最骄傲、最珍视自己自由的人。我的意思是，这就是他的核心观点，这就是他们与我们的区别所在。好吧，现在一切都已经就绪，一场惊天动地的大冲突即将来临。所以在我们的下一集——也就是第三集里，我们将探讨战争是如何爆发的，我们将研究《独立宣言》，并看看战争的进程将走向何方。所以我们在周一见，
they're hypersensitive is because they have slaves. And Burke says those who are free are by far the most proud and jealous of their freedom if they have enslaved people. I mean, that's his core point. That's the difference between them and us. Right. So everything is now set up for the titanic conflict that is to come. So in our next episode, our third episode, we will look at how the war begins. We'll look at the Declaration of Independence. And we will see what the course of war is so we will see you on monday
对吧，多米尼克？除非当然……除非有什么……等等，难道有什么……那些急切想要知道谁赢得了美国独立战争的听众，他们如果想提前知道的话该怎么办？如果你是“历史余音”俱乐部的会员，你就可以直接收听这些节目。你可以一口气听到底，就好像亚当·史密斯从未离开过一样。他将时时刻刻、无论你清醒还是睡眠都陪伴着你。带着这个重磅消息，我们下期再见。再见。再见。
won't we dominic unless of course less unless is there something that yeah listeners desperate to find out who wins the american war of independence if they can do that early if you're a member of the rest is history club then you can listen to these episodes straight away you can just plow straight on it's as as though Adam Smith has never left. He's with you constantly, waking or sleeping. So on that bombshell, we'll see you next time. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
再见。感谢收听《历史余音》。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁、无广告畅听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余音》。
Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
这是你们每周必看的娱乐新闻、精彩评论和八卦花絮。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐产业的神秘面纱，带你一探究竟。我们的会员俱乐部刚刚上线。如果你想享受无广告收听、加更节目以及提前抢购现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是您每周获取的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点娱乐圈八卦的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。